okay can we talk about these crab arms
and jason and the crab arms and
how do you dream that up well ben's the
weirdo that came up with it and
literally every step of the process like
okay we bring it to netflix and i was
like oh my god they want to make it how
exciting and he's like
i'm assuming in the first week i get the
call and i'm like we're going to get the
call
that's like yeah you see that can be a
crap
we know this and we kept waiting and
then like also then we're going to be
like a visual effects meeting and then
it's like oh this is the crab model
builder and we're like
what's going on when do we get the call
and ben's like i just literally had a
whole meeting about
building crab arms then the next thing
we're seeing models and where ben's like
when am i getting the call that says you
can't make someone have
crab and then bateman was just um
on certain crab arms and i was like this
is the greatest moment of my life
i know i have children but i was like
this
i think even bateman was like i can't
believe this is what's happening
let's see what these powers can really
do everyone just stay calm and no one's
going to get hurt
i'm stopped you're cooking them from the
inside out
oh man please don't film this first
thing
thunder force remember it octavia so you
see all this crazy stuff
do not throw that bus how hard was it
for you to keep
a straight face we all took the work
very seriously
because you know you you i
melissa's just so funny but i also
didn't want to be the person who
destroyed the tape
so you keep it together um you don't you
try
not to break but at the at the end of
the tape
everybody would just erupt into laughter
and then
you know calm down and do it all over
again so
it was it was it was hard to keep it
together on a lot of things
three two one go
melissa can can we just get into the
wire work all the crazy stunts and the
wires and the spinning
and i heard that you could barely keep
it keep it straight half the time
i just love it i don't know why i prefer
to be strung up and spun about a room
but i love it with my whole heart
probably because i can't do any of that
stuff anymore like i did gymnastics
back in the day and i i think i feel
like when i go up on wires and like i
can still do back handsprings
watch this i just don't have to deal
with gravity
but um and that also has an amazing
stunt woman that like
you know smooths the edges for me
well that's what i was gonna ask you
i'll tell you how much of it did you
guys get to do any stunts or were you
like
uh please come in stop i'm not melissa
i i i don't i don't i don't love uh or
relish the idea of
flipping around cartwright stuff um
i i i had to take some training
so that it would be believable when the
stunt woman actually
you know because she's so good and so
athletic um but yeah not everybody is
melissa mccarthy
um it's it's one of your best things
you're
gentle
[Music]
octavia how much fun was doing this with
someone who is such a good friend
um it was extremely fun i'd always
dreamt of being a superhero so when
two people that you personally love
and professionally admire um
bring you a script that for a character
that you've always wanted to play
and then it's opposite the most
versatile actress
in the world in my opinion um i was like
oh my god this is going
to be so much fun and it it actually was
it was so much fun um youtube goes so
far back
and um so the price is right explain
that
they explain
who cares about an oscar when you two
actually
hung out in an audition for the price is
right yeah listen
no thank you
tell the two short women to sit in the
back
i'm not sure she was gonna get it
because she's like lady luck she always
like
i think all of us that went were like
well we're going for support octane is
going to run down the aisle
like we were i was completely convinced
of it so we were shocked
when she didn't get picked oh by the way
octavia
what is your game on the price is right
because everybody has a game what was
your game that you were
i was ready for the showcase showdown
were you yeah like
like i i didn't know that i would get
there like playing the
picking the prices and you know or the
the little
guy that what was it the the mountain
like the mountain climber
the mountain climber yes i i liked him
but i was ready
because my dream was to win both
showcases
then i was always like and then how do
you get this it's like it's not like
cash or you win like a washer dryer and
a new dinette set i'm like
how do you get it home we all had little
apartments we couldn't have fit that
stuff in our apartments just
to save
was it true that you brought a puppy to
the audition
yes because i oh and i'd only had it we
were
so it was like after a i'm sure it was
after i know it was after groundlings
class
we would always go to the snake pit
which was a
fine dive of a bar on melrose
and i was i was in there and some
[Music]
super shady guy came in with a bag of
puppies
and we were like i just was like we have
to get these puppies away from this guy
because he was
up to no good and i had you know 12
to my name and he's like 64. 64.92 cents
i'm like
what we're in snake power if i if i hit
64. i wouldn't be drinking here
and uh so we and everybody in the bar
the bartenders the patrons
everybody gave me a little bit of money
and i was able to adopt this dog which i
called phil
and i got him at like you know midnight
the night before and then we were all
meeting at five in the morning and
price is right and i showed up i didn't
know i didn't know how to take care of a
dog i was like
oh phil poor phillip look at you now
phil moved to vegas with a friend and
destroyed his sprinkler system
[Laughter]
he took thousands of dollars worth of
damage